and stick it in the ignition
and then when i go to start it
it starts blinking
fast
the reason that that's blinking
[Music]
hello and welcome back to gears and tech
today we're sitting in our brand new
ford mustang i want to talk about keys
when we bought this car it had just this
one key now this key is a key fob it has
door unlock lock and also panic and a
trunk release the trunk release does not
work on this key plus i don't like
having only one key for my car i have
purchased this key which is a factory
replacement from amazon i'll put a link
in the description where you can get
this key what i'm about to show you will
work on any car pretty much from about
and older
this particular key it comes uncut it's
currently cut now and that's because i
took it to my local hardware store and
just said can you please cut this key
they should do that for you now in
canada i've had the most success going
to home hardware home hardware still has
the old machine where it clamps it in
and then it traces the key out if it is
a newer machine where they just stick it
in like what a walmart has they may not
cut the key for you that's because they
will check if it has a chip and if it
does they will not cut it because they
say that that can damage the chip the
vibration and it can
i have programmed hundreds of keys and i
have seen damaged chips now that the key
is cut and i can use it in the ignition
i will show you what happens with a
proper key and this cut key this is the
regular key so i'm going to stick it in
and on the dash here the key lock
indicator showing so when i stick it in
it'll blink once
and the car will fire right up no issue
now i'm going to take this key out i'm
going to take this
cut key
and stick it in the ignition
and then when i go to start it
it starts blinking
fast
the reason that that's blinking before
we get too far into this video don't
forget to subscribe to the channel down
below if you've seen some of our content
already and have not subscribed we want
you to join our community smash that
like button hit subscribe and let's get
back to the video the reason that that's
blinking is because this key has not
been programmed so we need to program it
so i know you're wondering what we're
going to use to program it it's not
super easy we are going to use special
hardware this hardware is available
again on amazon it is very inexpensive
it's actually cheaper
to buy the key from amazon and this
programmer than it is to pay somebody to
provide you the key cut it and program
it so you can do this once and have this
forever this is the ck 100 programmer it
plugs into your standard obd2 port and
it will program
hundreds of different keys with
different manufacturers it will program
this ford mustang it programs most fords
most chevys most pontiacs all that the
first thing we need to do is plug in the
obd2 connector so it's going to be
underneath here
plug it in make sure it's good and snug
it will immediately power on first thing
we're going to be greeted with is the
serial number and the last update is
from 2014 this is kind of old i'm going
to press f1 to continue now once in a
minute my main menu i'm going to go to
immobilizer i'm going to press enter and
then we're going to just pick our
vehicle i'm going to press this button
it tabs through the pages we're going to
go until we see f ford and we want ford
usa enter
now it's going to ask what kind of ford
is this
mustang this particular mustang is a
2010-2012
enter
now it's going to say pressing a key
i'm going to press any key now it says
insert a key and turn on the console i'm
going to take
my new key
and i'm going to stick it in
like that and i'm going to turn it on to
position two
[Music]
then i'm going to hit enter
and it's going to say please wait
connecting there we go now it's going to
say what do you want to do program new
keys
present errors or errors reset now if i
go present errors it's probably going to
give me an error for unknown key so
detected one errors
and it's pat's key failure that's okay
because i know
that i tried to use an unprogrammed key
in here so i'm going to reset that
delete errors yes terminated
escape there we go now i want to program
new keys and we can go erase all keys i
do not recommend erasing all keys the
reason i say not to erase all keys is
because
this key still works i have
erased all keys before and then had a
heck of a time trying to program a new
key if you erase all keys this key will
also stop working i can go number of
keys in memory so i can push that it
will connect and then it'll say there is
two keys in memory and again
i have one key so somewhere out there is
a ford key that will work on this car
and i don't know who has that key
but that's okay so i'm going to go to
add a key
and press enter and it's going to say
add a key insert the new key
turn ignition on so i still have the key
in
and it is still on this is the new key
this right here is the old key
now i'm going to press enter
and it's going to say safety access
procedure elapsed time
2 of max 800 seconds 800 seconds is
about 13 and a half minutes the reason
is it is a safety lockout procedure if
somebody had gotten a hold of one of
these tools
and if they somehow figured out what
your key code was and created a new key
for your car
based on that key code for example right
now somebody's looking at this key and
they know exactly what the key code is
for this key that's because each
individual cut at each specific location
is actually coded to a specific number
to where somebody could
make this key just from having a picture
of this key if
they got a picture of the key made a key
knew where my car was found my car came
to my car and brought this tool with
them they would have to sit in my
driveway for 13 and a half minutes doing
exactly what i'm doing right now just to
program the key so they could steal my
car this is more of a deterrent system
than anything
most auto manufacturers have some sort
of a lockout now depending on the
programmer that you have it may have a
lockout bypass and that's what that
would mean when you're looking at
different programmers and options that
they have this particular one does not
have a lockout bypass in the sense that
it will not bypass the timer but usually
around
seconds
the safety access procedure will be
complete and it will unlock the car and
allow it to accept the new
key chevy does this as well what dodge
does is they have a safety code and
access code and this programmer asks you
for that access code if you are
programming a different car and it's
asking you for that safety access code
sometimes you can call your dealership
and they will give it to you over the
phone or you have to come in and prove
that you own the vehicle before they
will give you that access code it is
your car it is your code you own that
code the dealership has an obligation to
release that code to you other
manufacturers like nissan has a access
code as well mitsubishi does a lot of
those manufacturers have access codes
rather than a timeout the ford
has just a timeout procedure no code is
required i'm going to sit here i will
show you when it's done and what it
looks like here we are just over halfway
through 500 seconds of 800. it is very
important that you do not play with this
or
with your key
while this procedure is taking place i
have seen this procedure fail before i
have sat for the 13 and a half minutes
and at 13.3
minutes
it has failed and i've had to redo it
now it will fail for a number of reasons
sometimes it just fails it's just a fact
of life and trying again is what's
required to make it work sometimes it
fails because the chip isn't working
sometimes it fails because you picked
the wrong vehicle sometimes it fails
because something's wrong with the
vehicle sometimes it fails because the
battery died keep in mind we've got the
ignition on right now my battery
indicator there is on saying hey start
your car your battery's gonna die we're
you know taking some risks here plus
keep in mind this is just a chinese
knockoff piece of equipment it is not
manufactured spec equipment it timed out
and it says the key has been stored
press any key so i'm going to press the
any key that's this one right here says
enter
and it says do you want to save customer
data i always say no it doesn't matter
and then takes us back to this
now let's shut the key off we're going
to cycle this this is the cut key last
time when we stuck it in we got the
lockout battery thing here so i'm going
to try and start
it and there we go
the car is now running with that key
i still have the original key here which
will make sure it works still take this
one out this is the brand new key we'll
put it up there where we can see it this
is the original key i always make sure
that the original key still works
just like that just to be sure
you need to understand that in this case
it does not program this part of the fob
these buttons
still do not work that's okay because
there is a separate procedure for
programming those buttons this key will
open the door and it will start the car
which is what we wanted to do we are
finished with this programmer so i can
unplug it
and we can set that aside over here what
i want to do is program these buttons
for the key fob and the way you're going
to do that is take the original key you
want to stick this in here recycle it on
and off eight times we're gonna leave it
on on the eighth time because this is a
dual headed key and it can go either way
you want to do it this way so that when
it's on the buttons are accessible and
that'll be important in a minute so here
we go one two three
four five
six seven eight
okay now that it locked and you've put
it into program mode like that
the horn honks and then we push this
you can hear the doors lock
and that has programmed this key fob and
this one should still works
and this is the new one
so if you follow these steps you can
program your ford key or pretty much any
other manufacturer there's a long list
of manufacturers that this programmer
works with so far i have found that
compatibility is actually quite high and
this is one of the most cost effective
programmers that you can get this one
the trunk popper wasn't working on
and if i push it it just it just never
worked
but
now this one
there you go
so you can see that works perfectly now
hey thanks for watching all the way to
the end of this video we hope you enjoy
the content in this video we'd love to
have you come back consider subscribing
to the channel if you haven't already
and for those subscribers who are
looking for that extra special thing
that you can do to support this channel
consider joining our members group
that's where we're building this
community the gears and tech community
where we can all enjoy content together
you'll get special perks which we'd love
for you to check out by clicking the
link down below for those of you who are
just happy to watch the video that's
okay too you can check out some of our
other content right over here where
we've got some previous videos that have
already been uploaded and enjoyed by
many of our viewers already we do hope
to see you again this has been gears and
tech have a great day